Nicole Leblanc vit avec la maladie
coeliaque une condition auto-immune
depuis 25 ans 25 ans durant lesquels la
nutritionniste retraitée s'est habituée
à ce que sa facture d'épicerie lui coûte
plus cher et facilement deux portions de
plus dans cette boîte-là par rapport à
la boîte sans gluten l'organisme Célia
Québec estime qu'un panier d'épicerie
sans gluten peut coûter jusqu'à 40% plus
cher qu'un panier d'aliments réguliers
un coup dur pour 86% des personnes
céliaques qui se disent gênés par ces
dépenses additionnelles il y a pas de
médicaments qui existent pour cette
maladie-là le traitement ça consiste en
une alimentation sans gluten stricte
pour la vie ce qu'on veut c'est rendre
ce traitement là accessible aux gens et
qu'ils soient remboursés d'une façon ou
d'une autre l'organisme demande à Québec
de mettre sur pied une aide financière
spéciale pour les personnes céliaques il
explique que contrairement aux autres
produits sans allergènes comme les noix
ou les œufs les sans gluten sont
considérablement plus dispendieux ça
finit par détruire la surface du petit
intestin puis empêcher l'absorption de
vitamines de minéraux de calories pour
le moment la seule aide financière
disponible est un crédit d'impôt fédéral
pour frais médicaux mais il implique un
processus complexe il faut absolument
avoir une preuve de diagnostic de notre
médecin ensuite de ça faut calculer le
différentiel du coût d'un aliment sans
gluten par rapport à un aliment régulier
une méthode qui n'est pas accessible à
tous pensez ou très peu de salariés qui
ne font pas de rapport d'impôts c'est
les gens qui en ont le plus besoin c'est
difficile pour eux d'aller vers les
Banques Alimentaires parce que il y a
pas nécessairement une offre de produits
sans gluten le ministère de l'Emploi et
de la Solidarité sociale confirme qu'il
a eu plusieurs discussions avec Célia
Québec il indique que la création d'une
prestation spéciale pour les
bénéficiaires de l'aide sociale ayant un
diagnostic de la maladie cœliaque
pourrait être év ici Flavie Sauvageau
Radio-Canada à Québec